So we have these three
ordered pairs which represent
how much time I've worked and
how much money I make.
I want to visualize these and
the best way to do that is with a graph.
And here is my graph paper.
This line here is called the x axis and
this one's the y axis.
The first thing I'm going to
do is decide on a scale.
And I'm going to choose a scale in the x
axis that goes up by fives, 5, 10, 15,
20, and of course zero here.
I am going to have my y
axis increment by 50 and
note this point here has zero for
its x value, n for its y value.
This point we call the origin but
back to our order pairs.
Well how am I going to
put 5,50 in the graph?
Well I'm going to look at
five which means, okay,
go over here to where x is five,
which is this line and
then I'm going to go up to where
y is 50, which is up to here.
And then I'm going to put a dot.
Likewise for 10,100.
Go over to 10, up to 100 and
put a dot, and again 20,200.
Over to 20, up to 200 and put a dot.
Once I have a few dots I
can start to connect them.
Now using this graph,
maybe you can answer a question for me.
How much would I make if I worked for
15 hours?
Enter your answer here and
I've already given you the dollar sign.